Hydra belonged to the phylum nidaria  which makes them a relative of jellyfish  and sea anemone their bodies are small  about 10 to 20 millimeters in length and  also quite simple composed of two  cellular layers around a central cavity  which acts sort of like the hydra's  stomach at the end of this cavity the  hydra's body gives way to tentacles  which surround the hydra's mouth hydras  usually secure themselves to hard  surfaces including stones and bits of  plants there the Hydra waits for food  its tentacles stretching up to three  times the length of its body in search  for prey like Crustaceans insects and  even small fish  [Music]